hello everyone the main mission of this
channel is to promote chess so I thought
it would be wise to promote some games
played by people who also promote chess
I don't know if you remember some two
months ago I showed the game by Kevin
sprocket and you all know Kevin sprocket
is a great chess blogger never Google
Kevin's braggart images or you know
you'll see a lots of lots of lots of
things
but for this first game I decided to
show a game by vehicle of limits
he's just player from Croatia a
candidate master although you know he
has a steady job works a lot he also
does a very nice job on promoting chess
on his blog chess essentials or chess
central's I will put a link in the
description below so you can check it
out it's a blog about chess games just
books chess everything he really puts a
lot of personal note into into writing
his articles so it's always quite
entertaining I do invite you to check it
out but let's see this let's see this
game it was played it was played in last
year's creation secondly it was the last
round and he's playing against Ivana
Porter
women feed a master of also from Croatia
and it's quite an interesting game I
asked the vehicle of if he had some
interesting games so I can show and he
sent me this one that's why I enjoy it
even more because he sent it to me
voluntarily and a lot of you remember
him you might be surprised why is there
a Draco Malfoy in the title well some of
you have met him in my 50,000
subscribers stream some of you also got
a chance to play against him and you
immediately named him Draco Malfoy
probably because he looks like Draco
Malfoy but as he's called his name is
via coastal Nimitz I simply call him via
KHOU Malfoy as of that time so so let's
see this game the echo has the white
pieces and he plays d4 he wanna respond
with Knight to f6 so starting with an
Indian game c4 e6 Knight to c3 and
Bishop to b4 the nimzo-indian defense
and we have f3 by via KO hear the
commotion c5 d5e captures C captures and
b6 now we have E for Ivana castles
Bishop to g5 now opening the night
Knight B to d7 and Bishop to d3 Queen to
c7 getting out of the bishops way Knight
to e2 and c4 now
Bishop to c2 and Queen to b6 stopping
stopping white from castling we have
Queen to d2 now rook to e8 and a3
kicking the bishop away Bishop to a5 now
opening up the attack to the b2 pawn and
Bishop to e3 attacking the Queen and you
can't really capture the pawn if you
play queen caps or son b2 this would be
this would be quite terrible as I'm sure
you all realize what is coming white
will simply play King to f2 and now
black isn't black is in big trouble here
rook rook H 2 b1 is coming and there's
really not a lot of ways you can stop
this
for example knight Knight to the c5 rook
H 2 b1
and what do you do here would the Queen
not a lot you do have to play something
like Knight to b3 with the attack on
White's queen but after rook captures
Queen Knight characters queen simply
Bishop captures on b2 and the white is
up a piece so capturing the beat upon
would be quite terrible
so after Bishop e3 Queen back to c7
we have castles by echo and Knight to e5
now maybe maybe planning some knife to
d3 in the future if white allows it but
also be 5 a beautiful square for the
knight h3 now preventing I mean putting
additional pressure to g4 so white will
be able to push f4 at some point Knight
to g6 Bishop to d4 now and here we have
Bishop to d7 and Bishop to d7 is
actually the move that starts losing the
game although White's position is better
but that's normal when you play
positions like this you manage to push
d5 you control more space this is
something black has to allow if she
wants to go for the win and here
something like Bishop to b6 would be a
more principled move your your your more
cramped in white controls more space so
the general idea is you want
as many pieces as you can add this is
spinning the bishop the dark square
bishop will get exchanged and so it
would be possible to continue this game
but after this Bishop to d7 move
via KHOU plays the instant Bishop
captures on f6g characters on it on f6
and this now will allow the Queen to
infiltrate the position with Queen to h6
and here white wants to play in Nigeria
Knight h5 threaten f6 support g7 when
the Queen comes to h6 but you can't go
night to g3 immediately if you play
Knight to g3 immediately you get Queen
to b6 check attacking the King and again
pressuring the B to pawn and after the
King moves now the Queen comes to b2
which tempo as there is now a double
attack on the knight on c3 so after y
defends this night the G back to e2 so
night to g3 as you can see would simply
be a waste of a tempo after Bishop to a4
now with a double attack on the bishop
on c2 that Bishop is also pinned it
can't move since Queen would capture
Queen and now it's actually black that
has the initiative so after this G
captures on f6 via KO plays first King
to h1 not allowing Queen to b6 with
tempo and now he's definitely ready to
go Nagi 3 to h5 so Bishop to b6 now and
I know you probably think ok if Queen to
h6 is such a terrible threat why not
King g7 stopping it well this wouldn't
really work since its if King g7 and 90
g3 to h5 will keep the King back so now
this will be a waste of a temple so okay
after king h1 Bishop to b6 now and
Knight the g3 King to h8 preparing this
rook to come to gh to defend g7 9th to
h5 we have Queen to d8 as the f6 pawn
was was under attack
Queen to h6 already this is move 22 via
KO is threatening checkmate on g7 rock
the g8 defending this and now at 4
we have Bishop to d4 now guarding f6
since f5 was a threat rook a to d1
attacking the bishop and here we have
night to f8 what's the idea here
well the idea after night to f8 is a
pretty sneaky one but maybe a better
move than nitro f8 would have been
Bishop captures on c3 for example and
after Bishop captures on c3 now Queen to
f8 going for exchanging Queens but after
Queen captures nine chapters in g4
White is so much better here this would
be this would be a nightmare for black
to play but after rook a to D one night
to f8 was played and what's the idea
here well the idea is if you capture the
Bishop rook captures on d4 you get rook
to g6 and the Queen is trapped on h6 so
instead of this vehicle played a five
now and this now really puts a lot of
pressure on black now roof g6 doesn't
make sense since the bishop is guarding
g6 f5 was played now Rob g6 again
becomes a threat but here comes Queen
captures on d6 grabbing that central
pawn and now look at look at these pawns
in the center this is beautiful rock to
g6 attacking the Queen and now E six
attacking the bishop the bishop on d4 is
still attacked so not a lot of choices
here he captures an F F captures an e6
was played and now simply rook capture
74 grabbing a piece Queen to h4 we have
Bishop to be one at protecting the
knight on h 5e captures on d5 and into
e5 trip we have King to g8 and now
Knight captures on d5 with ideas of
Knight to e7 check and here I wanna
place Bishop to c6 and this move will
prove to be deadly
here via KO play Knight to e7 check and
you don't really have a move here I mean
King to f7 is an option the only other
option is Queen captures night then you
lose the Queen so King to f7 was played
and here white is so much better that
white can pretty much play any move and
win the game so such such an idea would
be something like Knight captures on c6
b captures on c6 and the simple Bishop
to e2 and there is no defense against
Bishop captures on c4 but something
extraordinary happened
in this position after he wanna play
King to f7 in such a powerful position
via KHOU probably started daydreaming
he thought there's no way that he could
lose this game anymore maybe he was
already considering what to write as his
next post on chess Central's and maybe
maybe he completely stopped caring about
this game altogether and this is
something that often happens when you
have a completely winning position you
tend to ruin it so it's not over till
it's over and you should you should
really learn from this game in this
position via KHOU played Knight captures
on g6 and it seems like black is
completely crushed the queen is coming
to g7 with check this is over but now
look at this bishop this beautiful
Bishop on c6 is slicing all the way
there and it's spinning this sorry it's
spinning this pawn and g2 so in this
position you want to simply play the
Queen captures I'm h3 and the Queen can
be captured it's check and what follows
is King to g1 only move and the Queen
captures on g2 and this is checkmate and
what what what a game I mean what a
terrible loss for vehicle and I can only
imagine how he felt when you wanna play
this Queen captures on h3 check this is
I mean this will result in at least a
small nervous breakdown but you know
he's a cheerful guy you know he I'm sure
he got over it pretty quickly I mean I
presume so yeah that's the game you
should learn from it you know it's not
enough to play an excellent game to
really crush your opponent you also have
to wait until the game is over to start
celebrating or daydreaming or whatever
your plans are for that today or the
next day you have to finish the game so
like I said capturing the bishop
followed by Bishop e2 would be game over
but instead he captured that nice broken
g6 and this was the result so yeah
that's the game I would like to thank
vehicle for sending me this beautiful
game voluntarily I know it's you know
it's the best best face your failures
that's that's the only way you will
learn from
them I would like to thank work is IO
for a contribution to my channel and
through over by and latent Michaelson
I really appreciate it thank you a lot I
will continue with some games from other
people who also promote chests using
websites blogs or such and you know
never never Google Kevin's project
images never do that so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here like I said I will put a link to
chess centrioles in the description
below so you can check out to vehicle
Slavs blog and I will also put a link to
his Facebook profile so you know you can
write there something like haha you
missed meeting - or or whatever you
enjoy so yeah I will see you soon and
thank you for watching